[ Applause ]
Well, let's give -- and I said
it as I came down the steps.
We have people watching us
live on Facebook and YouTube!
So can we give a big hello
to everybody watching?
[ Cheers and Applause ]
I think that they heard you.
You know where you're here.
Do KBROU you think the
stage is scarry enough?
Will it give you goose bumps?
All right!
Well, I'm bringing in a
special lady who works
at the library, Ms.
Lee Ann Potter.
Give her a hand!
[ Applause ]
Because she is going to
introduce our special guest.
>> LEE ANN POTTER: Good morning.
We are so excited that you are
here, and what a special treat
to have the librarian
of congress welcome you this
morning È LEE ANN POTTER:
Good morning.
We are so excited that you are
here, and what a special treat
to have the librarian
of congress welcome
you this morning.
I want to do a few
special shout-outs to you.
I want to recognize the
students and their teachers,
as well as chaperons
who are here
in our library of
congress today.
And if you will hold your
applause until the very end
for yourselves, that
would be great.
From Washington dc,
we welcome students
from capitol hill
Montessori school.
Okay. One more time.
I'm going to read seven
schools, so we'll wait
until the end and chair.
From St. Patrick's day school,
from plumber elementary school,
from capitol hill -- from
Mori elementary school.
Also, we have a school from
Maryland, from hunting town,
the Langley school
in McClain, Virginia.
And as Dr. Hayden mentioned --
There are students
also watching us --
[ whispering ]
. It kind of works.
We're also excited that students
are viewing the program this
morning on the library's website
as well as the library's YouTube
and Facebook channels.
Later today you guys are
going to have an opportunity
to ask some questions
of your own,
and we also are inviting
students
who are watching the live stream
to send questions via Twitter.
And you can use the
hashtag #goosebumps
to ask your question.
It is my pleasure this
morning to introduce you
to our very special author.
R.L. Stine is one
of the best-selling
children's authors in history.
In July 1992, scholastic
introduced the first
"Goosebumps" book.
Nearly 25 years later,
"Goosebumps" is one
of the best selling children's
series of all times with more
than 350 million English
language books in print,
plus an additional 50 million
international copies in print
in 24 different languages.
The "Goosebumps" series
made R.L. Stine a worldwide
publishing celebrity.
His other POB popular
series, mostly ghostly,
the nightmare room, and rotten
school, it's the first day
of school forever, a midnight
scream, young Scrooge,
and two picture books
illustrated by mark brown,
the little shop of
monsters and Mary Mcscary.
His books have also inspired
movies and TV series.
The "Goosebumps" TV show was
number one for three years,
and episodes can still be
seen on streaming services.
And the feature film
"Goosebumps",
BAZ based on his book
series was released in 2015.
The sequel, "Goosebumps"
2, haunted Halloween,
will be released in a few weeks.
He and his is here
with us today.
Please join me in welcoming R.L.
Stine 2: Haunted Halloween",
will be released in a few weeks.
He is here with us today.
Please join me in
welcoming R.L. Stine.
[ Organ music ]
. È
R.L. STINE: You put
me near Slappy. È
LEE ANN POTTER: He scares
me a little bit. È
R.L. STINE: Slappy is evil.
I don't like sitting next to it.
How nice to be here today.
How many of you have ever
read a "Goosebumps" book?
Oh my goodness!
Thank you.
Thank you. È
LEE ANN POTTER: Quite a few. È
R.L. STINE: And how many of
you saw the "Goosebumps" movie
with Jack Black playing me.
Jack and I are like
twins, don't you think?
What do you think?
Not quite.
Not quite. È
LEE ANN POTTER: Fabulous.
I've got a very important
question for you.
In with the exchanges that we
have been having with colleagues
about this program, I was asking
how could I introduce you?
Do I call him R.L.?
Robert? Mr. Stine?
And someone said Bob. È
R.L. STINE: No one ever
called me R.L. all my life.
I used to be funny.
I wrote joke books
for a long time.
You want to hear one
of my best jokes?
Want to hear a joke?
It's a kids joke.
What do you get when you
cross a dog with a frog?
You get a dog that can lick
himself from across the room.
See? Now I made a living with
jokes like that, and I -- yeah.
All right.
It was -- I was known
as jovial Bob Stine.
And then I got scary, and I
started writing scary books,
and I thought that
jovial Bob Stine?
That's a horrible name for
a horror writer, right?
So I just used my initials.
And people always say
-- kids always say,
what does R.L. stand for?
And they pick something
scary . È LEE ANN POTTER:
I think it's great.
Yeah. Just a little bit.
So, I'm glad you mentioned that
you wrote jokes, because I read
that when you were about 9
years old, at the age of some
of our students in the audience,
that you found a typewriter
in a storage room and
started writing jokes ? È
R.L. STINE: My parents
didn't understand it at all.
My mother would stand
outside of my door and say,
"What's wrong with you?
Go outside and play!
Go outside!
And I would say it's
boring out there."
And type type type type type.
I have been doing
that ever since.
È RACHEL WILLIAMS: I
think È LEE ANN POTTER:
I think it's great.
Here at the library of congress,
this is the largest
library in the world.
We go into the card catalog
and try to get a sense
of how many books has a
particular author written,
and we're used to
seeing a handful.
When we did a search
on R.L. Stine,
we found hundreds of titles.
We're curious: Where do all
of your identities come from?
È R.L. STINE: I don't know.
Where do they come from?
We all get ideas, right?
I don't know.
I would tell you, how
many of you have read
"The Haunted Mask,"
or seen the TV show?
That's a Halloween story.
It's about a girl
named Carly Bets,
who wants to be scary
at Halloween time.
And she tries on a scary mask,
and it sticks to her face,
and she can't get it off.
And it becomes her face,
and it turns her evil.
And I will tell you where the
idea came from for that story.
It actually came from my son,
Matt, when he was a little guy.
It was Halloween, and
I was watching Matt.
He was down on the floor trying
on a green rubber
Frankenstein mask.
And he pulled it
down over his head,
and he couldn't get it off.
And I'm watching
from the doorway.
And he's down there, and he's
tugging and he's tugging.
And I thought, what
a great idea!
I should have helped him, right?
Instead, I went and started
making notes and saying oh,
great idea for a story.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Perfect. È
R.L. STINE: And poor Matt
is still in the mask.
It's a very sad story.
È LEE ANN POTTER:
I love it. È
R.L. STINE: You never know
where you're going to get ideas.
One day I was walking my dog in
the park, and these words popped
into my head: Say
cheese and die.
Why those words?
I started thinking, well, what
if there's an evil camera?
What if some kids
discovered the camera?
And what if the camera
took pictures of bad things
that happened to you a
little bit in the future?
And that's how that book, "Say
Cheese and Die" got started is
from those words
popping into my head.
You never know where ideas
are going to come from.
È LEE ANN POTTER: When
you have a unique idea,
I mentioned that the library
of congress is the largest
library in the world.
We're also home to the
U.S. copyright office.
Have you heard that word before?
So you have an idea, when you
write a book, one of the things
that you're encouraged
to do is submit that book
to the U.S. copyright office
so that you receive --
you own a copyright
on your work.
That means your ideas are yours
and your ideas are protected.
When we did a search on all of
the titles in our collection,
we asked our colleagues
if they would send
over to our office
a bunch of them.
So we have about 10% of the
books that are in the library
of congress that you
wrote with us today.
And many of these
books were submitted
when the copyright
was requested.
È R.L. STINE: Uh-huh. È
LEE ANN POTTER: And we
contacted our colleague
in the copyright
office, and we said Hey,
we don't suppose you have the
copyright registration forms
for all of the hundreds of books
that Mr. Stine has written,
and he responded
through an e-mail,
and he was like of course we do.
We're the U.S. copyright office.
I went by his office yesterday,
and we have a gift for you. È
R.L. STINE: A gift?
È LEE ANN POTTER: Yeah.
This is an official copy of
your very first copyright
registration form for the very
first good "Goosebumps" book.
How about that?
È R.L. STINE: Wow!
[ Applause ]
That's amazing. È
LEE ANN POTTER: We thought
that was pretty note. È
R.L. STINE: That was amazing.
The first one was
"Welcome to Deadhouse,"
and I think it was the
scariest book of them all.
I didn't know what I was doing.
It was the first one I wrote.
It didn't have the funny stuff.
I always like to do a book
that's scary and funny
at the same time, and
this one is just scary.
The second one, "Stay
out of the Basement,"
that had funny stuff in it.
I figured out what I was doing.
This is amazeing to see.
I have never seen
any of this. È
LEE ANN POTTER: We put a
copy of it on the screen.
It's a two-page form.
But we have lots of them. È
R.L. STINE: I guess
that's a good thing. È
LEE ANN POTTER: It
is a good thing.
When you wrote the
first "Goosebumps" book,
did you imagine that it
would become a series?
È R.L. STINE: When
I wrote the first one,
I thought we would
do two or three.
That was it.
I didn't know people
would like it.
I wanted to be funny. È
LEE ANN POTTER: Yeah.
È R.L. STINE: And I
didn't understand it at all.
And I used to go to
school, and I'd say,
"Why do you like these books?"
And kids would always
say we like to be scared.
So, I thought okay,
forget the funny stuff.
I'll be scary from now on.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Do you
guys like to be scared?
BF
[ Audience answered
affirmative atively ]
.
[ Children chattering
in the audience ]
. È R.L. STINE: I think
that was a yes or no question.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I think
it got am bunk ram crazy.
It's almost Halloween.
Want to tell a story?
È R.L. STINE: They
took my podium away.
I'm going to stand up anyway
and see if I can come over here.
Nope. The light is terrible.
And I'm going to tell you --
let me ask you a question first.
How many of you have
ever seen a ghost?
How many? No, no.
I mean a real ghost.
A real ghost.
Not on television.
Not in the movies .
Maybe I saw a ghost once.
I don't know.
I'm going to tell you.
You can help me decide.
I'm going to tell you a true
ghost story that happened
to my brother Bill and me when
we were kids back in Ohio.
It was Halloween time, and
Bill and I were very excited,
because it was the first
Halloween that we were allowed
to go out trick or treating
without our parents.
We were going out by
ourselves for the first time.
And we both got dressed
as ghosts.
We put sheets down,
and we cut out eyes,
and we were very scary ghosts,
and we got shopping bags,
big shopping bags to
collect all the candy.
And I took a can of
that silly string.
You know that stuff?
You squeeze it and
the string comes out?
Yeah. Just in case we
had to string somebody.
So, I tucked it in my costume.
And Bill and I went outside.
It was a cold October night.
I remember it was the
kind of cold that clings
to the back of your neck.
The ground was all crunchy,
hard from the frost.
There was a tiny sliver
of the moon half covered
in cloud high in the sky.
And Bill and I, we always
started out trick or treating
at Mrs. Dawson's house
across the street.
And that was just our tradition.
We always started there.
But now I looked
across the street,
and her house was
completely dark.
I said, "I guess
she's not home, Bill.
We'll have to go
on without her."
So we started at the next house.
We started trick or
treating down the block.
And my family was very poor.
We lived in a tiny little house.
There were blocks of very
tiny houses, which was great
at Halloween time, because it
meant you didn't have to go
up any long driveways.
You didn't have any long walks.
You could just go
from house to house.
So Bill and I, we went
three or four blocks down,
and then we went three or
four blocks and came back.
And by the time we came back,
our bags were just
bulging with candy.
And I looked across the
street, and I saw a light
on in Mrs. Dawson's
front window.
I said "Bill, I guess
she's back.
Let's go over there.
" As we went up her driveway,
I could see it wasn't a light.
It was a big Jack-o-lantern
with a big grin on its face
and yellow fire inside it.
We got on Mrs. Dawson's
front stoop, and I knocked
on the door, and we waited.
She didn't come.
So, I knocked again,
and I rang the bell.
She didn't come to the door.
Bill said, "She's in there, Bob.
Go ahead. String her."
So I took out the silly
string, and I raised it
to her door, and then I stopped.
I stopped, and I froze,
because I saw the Jack-o-lantern
in the front window had changed.
It wasn't yellow anymore.
It was a bright scarlet
red, and it had a big frown
on its face . A big scowl.
We were half way
down the driveway
when the front door swung
open, and Mrs. Dawson came out.
I remember she was in
this gray nightgown,
this long, gray nightgown.
I remember it fluttering
in the wind, fluttering.
And she said, "Why
did you wake me?
Why did you wake me?
" And I said, "Oh, I'm
sorry, Mrs. Dawson.
I didn't know.
I'm really sorry.
But can I ask you one question?
How did you do that with
your Jack-o-lantern?
" And she said, "Jack-o-lantern?
I don't have a Jack-o-lantern.
" And Bill and I
looked in the window,
and it was completely dark.
Nothing was there.
We ran across the street,
dumped out all the candy,
divided it all up, and we
never mentioned it again.
We didn't mention
the Jack-o-lantern.
We didn't say a thing about it.
The next morning, I woke up
and I thought, you know what?
I should apologize
to Mrs. Dawson.
We woke her up.
That wasn't right.
So, I got dressed for
school, had breakfast,
and went across the
street to apologize,
but there was a big truck
in Mrs. Dawson's driveway,
and these men going in
and out of her house.
And I went up to
one of the workers,
and I said, "What's going on?".
He said I guess you're
getting new neighbors, kid.
I said "Why?
What do you mean?
" He said, "Oh, I'm sorry.
Didn't you hear?
Mrs. Dawson died two weeks ago."
That's my true ghost story.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
È LEE ANN POTTER: I think
they liked that story.
È R.L. STINE: Do
you think maybe I made
up part of that true story?
È AUDIENCE: Yes! È
R.L. STINE: Do you think I made
up a lot of that true story?
Maybe. I don't know.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I love it!
So, I know that we all enjoy
the titles of your books.
And you've named a few of them.
Do you have any favorites?
È R.L. STINE: A
few favorite titles?
One of my favorite titles is
"Little Shop of Hamsters."
It's totally ridiculous.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Okay.
Okay. È
R.L. STINE: My favorite
book is the haunted mask.
I think that's my
best Halloween story.
And I always -- I like all the
books with Slappy, because --
and I've written a lot of them.
The new "Goosebumps" are called
goose bumps, slappy's world.
I love writing him because
he insults everybody.
He's very rude, and THAES
that's fun to write.
È LEE ANN POTTER: How do
you come up with titles?
È R.L. STINE: They come to me.
That's all I do.
Kids don't care about this.
I don't even try to come
up with ideas anymore,
because I've done every
story a person can do.
I just try to think of titles.
I'm doing a lot of Slappy
books, because he's so popular.
And Slappy is the
star of Goose bumps 2.
And Slappy is incredible
in the new movie.
The newest "Goosebumps" book,
I had a title "The
Ghost of Slappy."
I killed him, but of
course he comes back. È
LEE ANN POTTER: Yep.
Yep. I understand sometimes
you play games with students
where you give us a quiz,
whether it's a real
or fake title?
Should we play that?
È R.L. STINE: Let's do this.
Let's see how much you really
know about "Goosebumps"s, okay?
This is a list of
"Goosebumps" titles.
Some of them are real;
some of them are fake.
Let's see if you can
tell which ones are real
and which ones are fake, okay?
Just shout it out.
Shout out fake or real.
Okay? Here we go.
One, son of slappy.
È real ! È
R.L. STINE: You're right.
Number two.
You just have to shout it
once, and we'll be fine.
Frosty the abombable snow man.
That's fake.
Number three, the barking ghost.
You got it!
You guys are good.
Yeah that's real.
How about this one?
More Rons from marsons
from mars?
That is fake, but I think
that would make a great
"Goosebumps" title.
Morons from Mars.
I sent that title to my
editors, and I said let's do a
"Goosebumps" called "Morons from
mars," and they said I can't do
that because I might
offend the morons.
Let's try number five,
"It Came from my Nose."
That one's fake.
That one's fake. È
LEE ANN POTTER: That's
a good one, too. È
R.L. STINE: Creature teacher.
That one's real!
That one's real.
Attack of the 2,000
pound Datson?
How about eat Eat
your Breakfast?
That's fake, too, but that
would be a good title.
I think that's scary,
somebody eating your breakfast.
I think it would be.
And how about, I am
slappy's evil twin?
That one's real.
You guys are good! È
LEE ANN POTTER: I love it.
È R.L. STINE: You
guys are scary. È
LEE ANN POTTER: Book titles
do certainly give us a sense
of a book's content.
But sometimes it helps to have a
little bit more of a description
of a book when you're deciding
if it's a book you
want to read or not.
So, you guys know when you
go to a library, and you look
at your card catalog, not only
do you get the title of a book,
but you also get a
description of the book
that you're considering reading.
Well, those descriptions
are often written right here
at the library of congress.
We have a group of
colleagues who work
in the building next
door to this building,
in our Madison building,
who are part
of the library's
cataloging division.
And part of their
job is to read books
and then write descriptions
of those books that end
up in the card catalog.
And one of our colleagues
who does that,
her name is Anne,
and she's here, too.
I sent her a note and asked if
she remembers writing summaries
for any of R.L. Stine's books,
and she immediately responded
and said of course, and she gave
me a list of a bunch of them.
So, I'm going to read
you a couple of them.
One of the books that
you already mentioned,
"Welcome to Dead house."
Ann's the one who wrote
the summary for that book
that appears in the
card catalog.
It reads "Amanda and Josh
move with their parents
into an old haunted house
located in the strange town
of dark falls where people
are unlike any they have
known before."
Do you think it would be hard
to capture an entire book
in less than 30 words? È
R.L. STINE: That's pretty
good for two sentences. È
LEE ANN POTTER: Here's
another one.
The title of the book is
"Why I'm afraid of Bees.
" Garrett's dream is
about to come true.
He's going to exchange bodies
with another kid
for a whole week.
But the new body isn't human...
. that's a pretty
good description, too.
È R.L. STINE: It's a bee.
Where's that part?
È LEE ANN POTTER: The
title gave that one away.
È R.L. STINE: And a
night in the beehive.
HiHe sleeps in a
beehive all night.
I would hate that.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I don't
think I would like it either.
Might you like to read a
little from one of your books?
È R.L. STINE: I
could read something.
I thought I would read
you -- since we're here,
I might as well, you know?
This is the very first
chapter of the first
"Goosebumps" slappy's
world book.
It's "Slappy Birthday to You."
This is just how
the book starts out.
It has a really weird and
stupid chapter ending.
So, that's why I
like to read it.
On Ian Barker's 12th
birthday, he received a gift
that brought pain and terror
to him and his entire family.
But let's not get
ahead of ourselves.
Let's try to enJOIjoy Ian's
birthday for as long as we can.
Let's keep in mind that it
was not the birthday Ian had
hopped for.
It quickly became a day he would
have given anything to forget.
Ian came down to breakfast on
that sunny spring morning eager
for his special day to begin.
Almost at once, he had trouble
with his -year-old
9-year-old sister, molly,
but that was nothing new.
If you asked Ian how to spell
molly, he would say TROUBLE.
There were pancakes
on the table.
Molly liked her pancakes drowned
in maple syrup, and she used
up most of the syrup
before Ian had a chance,
but Ian didn't claim.
He was -- complain.
He was determined to be
cheerful on his birthday.
Then it came down
to the last pancake.
Mine, Ian said.
You've already had six.
But I saw it first,
Molly insisted.
She kept her fork poking
into the side of the pancake.
It's my birthday.
I should get what I want today.
You always think you should get
what you want, molly declared.
Molly has red hair and blue
eyes, and when she gets
into an argument, her freckled
cheeks turn bright pink.
Her mom turned from
the kitchen counter.
She had been arranging
cup cakes for Ian's party.
Fighting again?
We're not fighting,
we're disputing.
Oh, big word, Ian said.
I'm so totally impressed.
They kept their forks in
the last remaining pancake.
You're a jerk, molly said.
I know you know that word.
Don't call Ian names on his
birthday, Mrs. Barker said.
Wait until tomorrow.
She had a good sense of humor.
Sometimes the kids
appreciated it.
Sometimes they didn't.
Why don't you split
the pancake in two.
Good idea, Ian said.
He used his fork to divide
the pancake into two pieces.
No fair, molly cried.
Your half is twice
as big as mine.
Ian laughed and gobbled
up his half before molly
could do anything about it.
Molly frowned about it.
Don't you know how to eat?
You have syrup on your chin.
Ian raised the bottle.
How would you like
it in your hair?
Whoa. Mrs. Barker turned
away from the cup cakes
and stepped to the table.
Breakfast is other over.
You're 12 now.
You really have to
stop the fighting.
She squeezed Ian's shoulder.
Your cousins are
coming for your party.
I want you to be
extra nice to them
and don't pick fights
like you always do.
Benny and Johnny?
They always start it.
Ian always starts
it, molly chimed in.
Shut up, Ian chimed.
Just listen to me,
Mrs. Barker pleaded.
I want you to be
nice to your cousins.
They have been going
through a rough time.
Uncle Donny is out of work
and aunt Marie is getting
over the operation.
Can I have a cup cake now?
Ian slapped the table.
If she has one, I want one, too.
Have you heard a word I
said, Mrs. Barker asked?
And Ian raised his right hand
as if he were swearing an oath.
Hands off, Mrs. Barker said.
Go get your dad.
Tell him guests will
be arriving soon.
Where is he?
In his workshop,
his mom answered.
Where else?
Where else, molly mimicked.
Ian walked down the back hall
to the door to the basement.
He thought about
Johnny and Vinny.
They lived just a
few blocks away.
Johnny was 12 and Vinny was
11, but they looked like twins.
They were both big bruisers,
tough guys, big for their eyes.
Loud and GRAP grabby with round
heads and upturned pig noses.
At least that's how
Ian describes them.
The kind of guys that were
always bumping up against people
and each other and
always grinning
about something mean, mean guys.
They're just jealous of you.
That's what Mrs.
Barker always told Ian.
They're your only cousins, so
you have to be nice to them.
Ian opened the basement
door and went
down the stairs two at a time.
The air grew warmer, and
it smelled of GLU glue.
His father stood hunches
over his long work table.
He turned.
Hi, Ian. Hey dad, Ian
started, mom says --
her's a birthday surprise
for you, Mr. Barker said.
He reached both hands to his
face, plucked out his eyes
and held them up to Ian.
That's chapter one.
You like that ending? È
LEE ANN POTTER: I love it.
È R.L. STINE: Plucked
out the eyes?
Come on. È LEE ANN
POTTER: That's fabulous!
So you mentioned slappy? È
R.L. STINE: I know.
I know. Those may be
fake eyes, you know?
Ian's father is a
doll repair man.
Yeah. È LEE ANN POTTER:
Later in that boom --
book, we learn more
about Slappy,
who plays a starring
role in an upcoming film.
È R.L. STINE: Not "an" up
coming film, but Goosebumps 2;
haunted Halloween. È
LEE ANN POTTER: What
is it like --
È R.L. STINE: What is it like
to be a character in a movie?
To have somebody playing you?
Like Jack Black?
It's a weird thing.
I sit there, and they're
talking about me in the movie.
It's very strange.
I had a great time.
Jack Black is a terrific guy.
I'm so happy he plays me.
We had a lot of fun together.
And I went down, actually --
I had my 5 second
cameo in my first film.
I went down and I shot it.
We were in a school, and I
walk out, and Jack's there,
and I say, "Hello, Mr. Stine."
That's my line.
And he says, "Hello, Mr. Black.
" That was my five
seconds in the movie.
Guess how many times
they shot it?
Guess how many? È
LEE ANN POTTER: Three?
È R.L. STINE: 25.
They shot it 25 times!
I couldn't believe it.
And I was hungry.
It was lunchtime.
I wanted to go get lunch,
and they kept shooting the
scene over and other again.
So, I might be in the next one.
I might be in the new one.
È LEE ANN POTTER: So
we should look for you?
È R.L. STINE: Look
for me at the very end
of the film, the very end.
And Slappy, in this one,
it's a Halloween movie.
It's Halloween time.
And Slappy, in his evil way,
decides to bring
everything Halloween to life.
He goes into a drugstore, and
he brings all the masks to life
and all the Halloween
toys and all the costumes
and all the witch's hats
and all the creatures.
And everything comes to life.
It's an amazing scene at
the end of the new movie.
Just all of Halloween
everywhere.
And I have to warn you that
the scariest scene involves
gummy bears.
This is my favorite.
I know, they're cute, right?
You think they're cute...
but in this movie, it's not too
cute when gummy bears attack.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Yeah.
Yeah. È
R.L. STINE: It's really
pretty incredible.
That's my favorite thing
in the whole movie. È
LEE ANN POTTER: Great.
È R.L. STINE: So I
hope everyone goes,
a week from Friday.
"Goosebumps" 2 haunted
Halloween.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I have
a hunch that some students
in the audience might
have questions as well.
È R.L. STINE: That
would be good.
We won't be able
to hear them. È
LEE ANN POTTER: We have
three microphones stationed
in different parts
of our theater.
È R.L. STINE: Nice.
È LEE ANN POTTER:
And our colleagues,
Sasha and Colena have a couple.
And they are going
to be asking students
in their little quadrants of the
theater if they have questions.
So, students, if you have a
question, do raise your hand,
and let one of my friends with
the microphones call on you,
and when you ask your
question, if you would start
by saying your name, and
then ask your question,
and the rest of us will listen.
And we also have the
opportunity for those of you
who are watching our
programs on the live stream,
if you also have questions
that you want to ask ,
you can go on twitter and use
the hashtag HTH #goosebumps,
and your questions can
be answered as well.
So, how about you find
someone with a question?
Who has a question ? È
tell us your name
and the question? È
my name is Chris, and my
question is how old were you
when you made your first book?
È R.L. STINE: How old was
I when I made my first book?
The first book I ever
had published was called
"How to be Funny.
" It was how to be
funny in school and how
to get big laughs
at the dinner table.
Parents hated this book.
They hated it.
And I was 28.
È LEE ANN POTTER: 28.
Great. È
R.L. STINE: I was 9 when I
started writing, but I was 28
when I had my first
book published.
È LEE ANN POTTER:
Excellent question.
Sasha, how about you?
È SYDNEY ANDERSON: È
a question from online,
from my son, what was the
hardest book for you to write?
And what was the easiest? È
R.L. STINE: They're
all pretty easy
for me . I write ten pages every
day, and I never have trouble.
I can always write
my ten pages a day.
There was a "Goosebumps"
book called "Cry of the Cat"
that I had to write three times.
Nobody liked it.
That happens.
Once in a while, that happens
where I write a book and none
of my editors like it.
And they send it back. È
who are your favorite
characters in your
"Goosebumps" movies and why?
È R.L. STINE: Well,
I really enjoy myself.
[ Laughter ]
I like Jack Black.
Don't clap for that!
It's all new kids
and a new family.
And the three kids in the movie,
I think you will like them.
And I think maybe you will
recognize some of them,
the boy from "It,"
he's in the film.
Yeah. And I -- they
are just wonderful.
They're a great part
of the film.
I think you'll like them.
È My name is Sophia,
and my question is
who is your favorite evil person
from goose"Goosebumps"
and why? È
R.L. STINE: Here's my favorite
monster, how many of you saw
"Welcome to Camp Jelly Jam.". "
Jelly jam is a huge BLOP blob.
This is my smelly book.
He smells so bad, he has to
be bathed 24 hours a day.
So, all the campers that come to
his camp, that's what they do.
They bathe him all day
long and all night.
And then finally, I'm going
to spoil the ending for you.
They get -- yeah.
I am. I'm going to.
They decide they've
had it with him.
It's enough.
And they stop bathing him, and
he dies from his own smell.
[ Laughter ]
That's my favorite.
I love him.
I love him. È
LEE ANN POTTER: Up there. È
what was your favorite and least
favorite books you have written?
È R.L. STINE: These
are hard questions.
There's a fairly recent one
called "Attack of the Jack,"
and it's about Jack-o-lanterns
that come to life.
But I really like this book
because there's a
talking cat in it.
There's a talking
cat in the book,
and I can't believe they
let me get away with that.
So, that's one of my favorites.
Then there's some
that are, you know,
I don't really like that much.
I shouldn't talk about this.
But there's a "Goosebumps"
book called the barking ghost
that I don't think
is very good . È
After the second
"Goosebumps" movie,
will you make a third one?
È R.L. STINE: If
everyone comes to this one,
I think they'll want to
make another one, right?
If people don't go, I
think that'll be it.
One and two.
You never know.
I would love to do
more movies. È
We have a question on Twitter.
What is the greatest piece
of advice you would give
to an author just
starting out? È
R.L. STINE: The best advice I
would give, I never give advice.
I never give advice,
because I always think people
who are going to become
authors and really want
to be authors are like me, and
they just write all the time.
They're always writing.
And you don't have to show
them why don't you write.
You don't have to tell them to
read a lot, because they do.
I always think they're like
me, and they don't need advice.
They just want to keep writing
and writing and getting better.
So, I never give advice.
È My name's Theo,
and my question is,
what is your favorite scene in
the original goose BUMPGS --
goose goose "Goosebumps"
movie? È
When they are on top
of the Ferris wheel sitting
and talking together?
I think that's a
really sweet scene.
And I love that scene.
I just think they
are so terrific.
That's my favorite scene
in the first movie. È
LEE ANN POTTER: That's
a great question. È
R.L. STINE: I have never
been asked that question.
That's a first.
È My name is terra.
If you made a new goose
"Goosebumps" book,
what would it be?
È R.L. STINE: I just started
a "Goosebumps" book called
"The Dummy meets the Mummy.
" You can kind of GETSS guess
what that's about, right?
È LEE ANN POTTER: I
like that sneak peak.
È My name is Bryce,
and my question is,
how did you invent Slappy,
and why is it so popular?
È R.L. STINE: That's
a good question.
That, I couldn't answer.
When I was a kid,
I loved puppets,
and I had mare owe puppets
and would do shows and things.
I WUDS was always interested.
Here's a terrifying story.
When I was really
little, I was so little
that I still had to take a nap.
And my mother would
read a chapter of a book
to me before my nap every
day . I'm this tiny guy,
and for some reason , she chose
to read the original PI
NOEK Pinniocchio to me.
He's a wooden puppet.
He falls asleep with
his feet on the stove,
and he PURN burns his feet off.
I never forgot that.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I wonder
if your nap was good that day.
È R.L. STINE: I don't know if
my nap was good or not that day.
I never forgot that and I
have always been interested
in puppets, and I think
that's how Slappy came to be.
It's funny how much Slappy looks
like Jack Black these days.
He's kind of changed, huh?
Time nor for a couple more? È
How about this one right here?
È R.L. STINE: Who has
a really good question?
È My name is Stacey, and
what's your favorite part
of a book out of all
of your books ? È
R.L. STINE: I like the ending.
It means I'm done.
I like the ending.
Who has a really good question?
È Sasha, in the back?
È My name is phoenix, and I
was wondering, what inspired you
to create "Goosebumps"?
È R.L. STINE: To
do the book series?
Is that the question?
I was doing a series for teens.
I was doing a scary book
series for teenagers,
which I'm still doing
called "Fear Street.
" It was teens in terror and
horrible things happening
to anybody who moved
to Fear Street.
And my editors came
to me and said,
Why don't we do a scary book
series for younger kids,
and I of course said no.
I didn't want to
do "Goosebumps".
That's the kind of
business man I am, right?
And they said no.
No one has done it.
Let's try it.
And so I said okay.
If I can think of a good
name for the series,
then maybe we can try a couple.
And one day I was
reading TV Guide.
In those days, it had
the program listings
in the middle of the magazine.
It told you what was on TV.
And I'm going through
the magazine,
and there was a tiny ad
at the bottom of the page,
and it said "It's goose
bumps week on channel 11,"
and I stared at it and
thought that's perfect.
We'll call it channel 11.
That's a bad joke.
I apologize.
That's a very bad joke.
But that's where the name
good "Goosebumps"s came from.
È LEE ANN POTTER: I think one
more question, and we're good.
È We have one back here. È
R.L. STINE: One more.
All right.
È My name is Travis,
and my question is,
the new movie "Goosebumps"
from the new characters?
È R.L. STINE: Say it again?
È From the new goose
bumps movie, are you going
to make the book from
the new characters
in the goose bumps movie?
È R.L. STINE: Yeah,
well there are two books
out about the new movie.
And they are both
telling the story
with the new characters
and everything.
All new characters.
Yeah. There are two books. È
RACHEL WILLIAMS: We
have a final question
from our friends
watching online.
È My daughter's
only 8 months old,
so she has a little time
before we get to "Goosebumps"s,
but I remember the
bookshelf where I picked
up "the Barking Ghost.
" So do you have
recommendations ifs
for a costume based
on your books? È
R.L. STINE: She's
eight months old?
My grandson Dylan, when
he was 2 -- he's 4 now.
When my grandson Dylan was
2 years old, he was going
out for Halloween as Slappy, and
I had Slappy in my apartment.
I had the dummy.
And Slappy's clothes
fit my grandson.
They fit him perfectly.
So, we took the clothes off
the dummy and Dylan went
out for Halloween as Slappy
wearing Slappy's clothes.
That's pretty good, right?
È LEE ANN POTTER: Perfect. È
R.L. STINE: He never
gave them back.
Poor Slappy doesn't have
a shirt or anything.
But I don't know about
costumes for an 8 month old.
È LEE ANN POTTER: This
has been so much fun.
È R.L. STINE: This
has been great.
Thank you all so much.
Thank you!
[ Cheers and Applause ]
È R.L. STINE: You're perfect.
Thank you so much.
È LEE ANN POTTER: On behalf
of the library ofLibrary
of Congress, Bob,
R.L., Mr. Stine,
thank you so much
for being here.
Thank you for responding to our
questions and thank you for all
that you've done to inspire
so many young readers.
And really, best of luck
to you and we are excited
about your new film. È
R.L. STINE: Thank you.
What a great morning.
Thank you.
È LEE ANN POTTER: Thank you.
[ Applause ]